felicidades estás en el último paso de
esta lección para finalizar lo que hemos
visto de los promedios ponderados
recuerda que si elijo los pesos 11
obtengo curvas subdivididas que se ven
así y aprendimos que estas formas son
pedazos de curvas de segundo grado como
he igual la x cuadrada y si elijo los
pesos 121 obtengo curvas que se ven más
suaves como esta estas curvas resultan
ser pedazos de curvas de tercer grado
como ye igual a x al cubo en este
ejemplo hay cuatro piezas distintas de
grado 3 puedo lograr curvas todavía más
suaves al poner los pesos 1331 que son
curvas de cuarto grado como de igual a x
a la cuarta y resulta que los pesos se
tienen que escoger cuidadosamente para
que las curvas sean suaves pero qué
significa exactamente
ser cuidadosos estos números 1 1 1 2 1 1
3 3 1 todos vienen de un patrón llamado
triángulo de pascal
veamos qué pasa si escojo pesos que no
están en el triángulo de pascal ni
siquiera tengo que elegir pesos
positivos así que supongamos que elijo
uno menos 2 3 nada nuevo con dividir eso
siempre agrega puntos medios pero cuando
hago el promedio
si continúo subdividiendo la curva se
vuelve menos y menos suave es algo
llamado fractal
conocemos todas las herramientas
matemáticas que se requieren para
mostrar esto y existen conceptos más
avanzados del álgebra lineal y algo
llamado análisis propio análisis propio
suena un poco intimidante pero los
matemáticos son muy buenos para poner
nombres que son algo intimidantes y
justo como hemos hecho hasta ahora
aprendemos un paso a la vez lo más
importante que quiero que sepas es que
las superficies que ves en nuestras
películas en realidad son muy fáciles de
crear el departamento de arte crea
bocetos para que los modeladores tengan
una referencia al momento de determinar
las posiciones de los puntos de control
a partir de ahí las herramientas del
software hacen la división y los
promedios para producir hermosas
superficies como las que ves en el cine
cuando estás viendo algunas de nuestras
películas no quiero que pienses en nada
de esto quiero que te sientes te relajes
es que la película te lleve lejos
entonces a jugar con los pesos y cuando
termines puedes pasar al ejercicio final